"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Abdourahman Waberi,
pourquoi Djibouti
a été la dernière
colonie française en Afrique
à obtenir et à gagner
son indépendance ?
C'était en 1977, au terme
d'un référendum, d'ailleurs.
-Il y a la version,
on va dire optimiste.
On va dire que les Djiboutiens,
- qui s'appelaient à l'époque
même pas Djiboutiens
puisqu'on s'appelait
le Territoire français
des Afars et des Issas -
voulaient continuer
l'aventure au moins
pendant 17 ans avec la France.
Ca, c'est le scénario optimiste.
Le scénario pessimiste,
je dirais qu'après
l'affaire comorienne, par exemple...
-Les années 75,
74-75.
-Deux ans avant.
Les autorités coloniales de l'époque
se sont arrangées pour...
ne pas vraiment publier
les vrais chiffres.
Donc on aurait un peu triché.
Si on regarde le décompte
des votes, on voit que les votes
dans la brousse, comme on dit,
sont bizarrement trop pro...
on va dire Territoire français,
alors qu'en ville,
il y a plus d'indépendantistes.
-Les citadins
étaient plus pour l'indépendance ?
-Donc on peut imaginer l'influence
du gouverneur de l'époque.
En tout état de cause,
Djibouti est restée 17 ans
dans la colonisation,
et est simplement devenue
indépendante en 77,
alors qu'il y avait
un courant indépendantiste.
-17 ans, mais Djibouti
était française
depuis pas mal de temps...
-1860...
-Oui, au 19e siècle.
Mais il y a eu deux tentatives
de référendum,
deux référendums, d'ailleurs,
où les Djiboutiens ont dit non,
en 1958 et en 1967.
-Oui.
-C'était la Côte des Somalis,
qui est devenue
le Territoire des Afars
et des Issas.
-Territoire français.
Je suis né français.
-A l'époque, il y avait
200 000 habitants.
Aujourd'hui, il y en a un million,
à peu près.
C'est un territoire étonnant,
parce que c'est dans la corne
de l'Afrique, qui est particulier
à plus d'un titre.
Le premier, c'est que c'est
un tout petit Etat charnière,
entre les mondes arabe et africain.
-Tout à fait.
C'est même une cité-Etat,
quasiment.
C'est vrai qu'il y a quatre...
On appelait ça des cercles,
maintenant, des régions.
Il y a quatre régions,
quatre grandes villes,
mais c'est quasiment
une cité-Etat.
-Qui s'appelle Djibouti.
-République de Djibouti.
-Vous vous sentez
plus proche de la culture
arabe ou africaine ?
-Alors Djibouti,
la population,
on va dire qu'il y a quatre groupes,
puisqu'il y a quatre langues
nationales.
Le français est une langue
nationale, à Djibouti.
Il y a l'arabe aussi
qui est une langue nationale,
parce que depuis le 19e siècle
habite une communauté
d'origine yéménite,
qui est djiboutienne aujourd'hui.
Le Yémen est juste en face :
14 miles marins.
Et d'autre part, la population
locale africaine
est elle-même en deux groupes :
groupe Somalis, à peu près 60 %,
- les chiffres sont compliqués -
et le groupe Afars,
qui est quasiment très proche
du groupe Somalis,
sauf qu'on partage pas
la même langue.
On partage un certain nombre
de traits, comme le nomadisme,
l'islam, l'habitat désertique,
etc.,
mais c'est quand même
deux groupes différents
puisqu'ils partagent plus
la même langue.
-Vous êtes à un point
tout à fait stratégique,
et c'était déjà le cas
à votre indépendance
quand la France
avait une base militaire,
la plus grande française en Afrique,
mais à cette base militaire
sont venues s'ajouter
d'autres bases militaires,
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui,
il y a une base
militaire américaine,
une base militaire japonaise,
une base militaire chinoise,
une base militaire allemande...
Tout est grignoté
par les bases militaires,
c'est incroyable.
C'est exceptionnel.
-Oui, c'est un cas unique.
Quelqu'un avait écrit :
"la diplomatie des petites nations".
Donc en fait, Djibouti,
je le déplore, s'est spécialisée...
Il y a des monocultures,
dans certains pays.
Par exemple, Côte d'Ivoire
devrait être une monoculture
de cacao, etc.,
et donc par-devers nous,
on va dire, Djibouti est devenue
une monoculture de bases militaires.
Donc la base française,
qui est là depuis le 19e siècle,
l'Etat de Djibouti actuel
a aussi profité
de certaines crises, comme la guerre
contre l'axe du mal, dirait Bush,
et à l'époque,
même la France commençait
à dire : "On baisse la base
militaire et on se retire."
Donc la guerre du Golfe
a déjà remis le métier sur le fil,
si j'ose dire, donc la base
militaire américaine
est devenue très importante.
Maintenant, on a,
comme on l'appelle,
la route de la soie...
-La base chinoise.
-Voilà, la Chine qui exprime
une volonté hégémonique mondiale,
donc la Chine a aussi mis le paquet,
a fait une grosse base.
Donc on a au moins trois grandes
bases à Djibouti :
la française historique,
l'américaine, la chinoise.
Sur ce viennent s'ajouter,
pour des histoires de piraterie,
dirait-on,
une base italienne
et japonaise.
Les pays du Golfe étant pas loin,
tout le monde
veut avoir son morceau.
-Dans ces conditions,
est-ce que Djibouti
peut vraiment prétendre
être indépendante ?
-C'est une question
qui est très difficile
à répondre.
Les autorités sont très dépendantes
de la manne financière
qui vient des bases,
ça, c'est sûr.
Le Djiboutien que j'étais,
n'é pendant la colonie française,
connaissait cette culture...
-Dans les années 60.
-Les années 70.
Je suis né dans les années 60,
mais adolescent dans les années 70.
Nous avions cette culture
de voir des militaires,
des jeunes appelés du contingent,
avec lesquels on fraternisait.
On avait des différences, mais...
Donc aujourd'hui,
les Djiboutiens, les enfants,
- je vis pas là-bas,
mais ce qui serait mes enfants, -
ne connaissent pas
les militaires américains.
Les GI enfermés chez eux,
comme les Chinois,
et ils ne viennent plus.
Il y a des histoires de sécurité,
mais il n'y a plus la culture
que je connaissais du mélange,
de cette base militaire française
qui faisait partie du décor.
Ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui.
-Alors autre particularité,
mais pas tant que ça si on compare
avec d'autres pays africains,
c'est que depuis 1977,
vous n'avez connu
que deux présidents...
-Ah oui mais ça...
-...le président Aptidon
et le président Guelleh,
aujourd'hui, qui n'est autre
que le neveu du précédent.
-Absolument.
-Donc c'est une histoire clanique,
familiale, Djibouti.
-Bah je vous apprends rien.
-Tout le monde le sait pas.
-Non, tout le monde ne sait pas.
-Ca, c'est le président Guelleh.
-Ismaïl Omar Guelleh,
qui est président depuis...
Il était déjà directeur
de cabinet de son oncle,
donc qui est aux affaires
depuis 96, ça fait un moment.
Et d'ailleurs, la question
de la suite se pose,
comme beaucoup de cas,
et nous n'avons bien sûr
pas connu d'élections libres,
et nous n'avons pas connu encore
de transition en douce.
La question de la transition
se pose dans beaucoup de pays,
en Afrique, et comment
concilier la démocratie,
les attentes du peuple
et la stabilité du gouvernement,
de l'Etat lui-même,
de l-Etat-Nation.
Ce sont des choses sur lesquelles
nous sommes pas encore au point,
à Djibouti et dans d'autres
pays africains.
-Aujourd'hui, nous sommes
dans une situation compliquée
sur le plan mondial,
avec une guerre au coeur,
enfin en Europe de l'Est,
avec l'invasion
de la Russie en Ukraine,
et il y a une opposition
qui se manifeste de plus en plus
entre l'Occident
et ce qu'on appelle,
selon une formule nouvelle,
le sud global,
c'est-à-dire les pays qui refusent
la domination occidentale,
et on a l'impression
que l'Afrique est un peu
l'otage de cette rivalité
entre le sud global,
mené par la Chine, par la Russie
d'ailleurs aussi,
et l'Occident,
c'est-à-dire
les Etats-Unis et l'Europe.
Est-ce que vous le regrettez, ça ?
-Je sais qu'il y a...
D'un point de vue intellectuel,
je suis contre les oppositions.
Je suis plutôt quelqu'un du lien...
-Du passage ?
-Du passage
et de la relation,
comme dirait Edouard Glissant,
de la créolisation,
mais je reconnais
qu'il y a évidemment des oppositions
binaires parfois très fortes.
Donc ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
le Sud global
contre une espèce
d'Occident fantasmé, aussi,
qui est unifié à dessein,
n'est pas tout à fait nouveau.
A la conférence de Bandung,
il y avait la tricontinentale.
-C'est une conférence
en Indonésie
en 1954.
-Oui.
Il y avait déjà...
-Et qui réunit les non-alignés
sous la tutelle de Nehru
et de quelques autres.
-En tout cas, déjà,
on les présentait
comme une suite qui serait
ni alignée à Moscou ni à Washington
et qui aurait sa voie,
donc ça existait.
Aujourd'hui, avec Wagner,
on voit aussi
que la Russie essaie de prendre...
-Pied en Afrique ?
-En République centrafricaine,
au Mail, etc.
Donc ça fait partie
de la géopolitique,
les blocs ne sont jamais mouvants.
Ce que je retiens, c'est pas tant
l'opposition de cette manière,
mais plutôt aussi
qu'il y ait une voix...
J'entendais les président kenyan,
Ruto, qui parlait d'une...
Il appelle ça une dollarisation :
pourquoi on utiliserait,
entre Djibouti
et Nairobi, qui est juste à côté...
-Le dollar ?
-Oui.
On pourrait,
pour certains échanges, puisqu'on a
des structures régionales...
C'est ce débat-là.
Que les Etats africains cherchent
une forme de sortie d'autonomie
me paraît être
une idée intéressante,
sans qu'ils retombent toujours
sur la domination d'un autre.
C'est pas la Chine qui m'intéresse,
pas une Afrique au service
de la Chine ou de la Russie,
mais une Afrique qui s'inventerait
à la fois à la base...
-Qui gagnerait son indépendance ?
-...par des processus régionaux.
-Vous avez écrit un livre
qui a un très beau titre :
"Rift, routes, rails".
Une des thèses centrales
que vous défendez,
c'est que l'Afrique a été dépossédée
d'elle-même, non ?
-On parle de plusieurs choses.
Mais disons que le discours
qu'on a sur l'Afrique
n'est pas un discours africain,
d'une certaine manière,
pour des raisons historiques.
Une grande partie
de tous les discours d'unification
vient des Caraïbes.
C'est eux qui...
Pour prendre la culture populaire,
le reggae...
-La Jamaïque.
-Voilà.
-Le reggae a imaginé,
avec à sa tête
Haïlé Sélassié à l'époque...
-En Ethiopie.
-...cette idée d'une Afrique
réunie, unifiée.
C'est un discours que ce qu'on
appelait les églises éthiopiennes
et caraïbéennes ont porté.
C'est le nouveau monde qui avait
besoin d'une Afrique unie.
Ce sont des discours sur l'Afrique
qui n'ont pas forcément
d'essences africaines.
De même, le discours...
A Djibouti, je travaillais
sur la bibliothèque coloniale.
Quand j'ai voulu parler de Djibouti,
le seul lieu où je trouvais
le nom de Djibouti,
c'est chez Monfreid,
chez Kessel...
-Des écrivains français.
-C'est ce qu'on appelle
la littérature coloniale.
C'est là que Monfreid
a écrit sur Djibouti
avant que j'arrive
à écrire sur Djibouti.
Là, je trouve Djibouti
dans la bibliothèque qui serait
la moins, n'est-ce pas,
indiquée au départ.
Ces contradictions-là
m'intéressent.
Le discours sur l'Afrique dirait...
Le philosophe Mudimbe appelle ça
la bibliothèque coloniale.
Ce sont des discours fabriqués
par l'anthropologie,
par l'histoire coloniale,
par la médecine coloniale, etc.,
PAR les libérations américaines
au sens caraïbéennes.
Les églises caraïbéennes
ont inventé une forme d'Afrique.
Ces discours-là ne disent pas
grand-chose,
nous disent si peu de choses
sur les Afriques réelles.
-C'est intéressant
que vous utilisiez ce pluriel,
parce que vous avez écrit,
avec Alain Mabanckou,
un "Dictionnaire enjoué
"des cultures africaines".
Que vouliez-vous montré par-là ?
Réhabiliter des cultures perdues ?
On vous voit tous les deux.
-Nous sommes à la fois
des artistes et des enseignants.
On voulait faire un dictionnaire
sur le modèle d'autres dictionnaires
que vous connaissez, chez Plon...
-"Le dictionnaire amoureux"...
-Oui.
Donc avec Alain, on a imaginé
une manière d'ouvrir,
comme si on ouvrait notre malle,
une malle à histoires,
et on sortait des articles
en disant...
Si je vous parle de Rimbaud,
pour moi, c'est un Africain.
-Il est passé à Djibouti.
-Qui voulait même y mourir.
Il y a pas plus africain
et attachant qu'Arthur Rimbaud.
C'est une manière
à la fois
de vulgariser la bibliothèque
commune entre Français et Africains,
et aussi de faire
oeuvre d'éducation,
et populariser aussi.
-Vous avez parlé de Kessel,
de Monfreid,
qui sont passés à Djibouti,
des grands voyageurs.
Est-ce que les histoires
qu'ils ont racontées,
vous vous les réappropriez,
vous estimez
qu'il faut les revisiter ?
Est-ce que vous participez
à ce mouvement très important
aux Etats-Unis,
et vous devez le croiser
à où vous enseignez à Washington,
le wokisme,
où on remet en question...
-Non.
-...certains vérités historiques ?
-Non parce que le wokisme est...
Déboulonner les statuts,
c'est un débat de type...
politico-social
qui peut parfois se justifier.
Ce que nous voulons faire,
c'est revisiter les bibliothèques.
Ce qui m'intéresse
chez Kessel, c'est qu'il ait pu
écrire des choses sur les miens.
Le livre est sur moi, je vais
le lire et me l'approprier.
Pour Monfreid, c'est pareil,
pour Loti, c'est pareil.
Je trafique
avec cette littérature.
C'est pas des gens avec qui
je suis en opposition.
Ce serait même des grands-oncles
qui sont pas là,
que je chérie,
parfois que j'engueule,
mais ils font partie
de mon histoire.
-Vous avez lu
"Le roman d'un Spahi" de Loti ?
La vocabulaire
a dû vous gêner, non ?
-C'est d'époque.
-Voilà, vous comprenez ça ?
-Evidemment qu'ils disent
"Noir" ou nègre".
C'est pas écrit d'aujourd'hui.
Il est même pas là.
Ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est ce que j'en fais.
Je vais pas le faire disparaître,
mais le remettre en circulation
et l'utiliser en enlevant
deux-trois mots.
C'est ça, l'histoire.
Moi qui suis un jeune...
Je suis plus jeune.
mais quand j'étais écrivain,
on me disait jeune écrivain.
Pourquoi je vais revendiquer
qu'une partie de l'histoire ?
-Oui.
-Donc je suis pas
dans le déboulonnage
mais dans la relation.
-Vous êtes très attaché
à la francophonie, d'ailleurs.
-Je voudrais une francophonie
de tous les jours, pas d'exception,
où on se retrouve au mois de mars
pour fêter la francophonie.
La francophonie appartient à tous
les usagers de la langue française,
et on voudrait la fêter,
la célébrer tous les jours.
-Certains disent que c'est
un instrument néocolonialiste.
-Qu'elle vienne dans les bagages
du colonialisme, c'est évident,
mais aujourd'hui,
personne ne demande
d'écrire d'une telle manière
ou d'une autre.
Quand vous avez des écrivains
à Abidjan qui la créolisent...
A Abidjan, il y a un argot nouchi.
Si vous écoutez
la chanson ivoirienne
du coupé-décalé, c'est du français
mais qui a déjà évolué.
Personne n'est allé
légiférer là-dessus
donc ça appartient
aux Ivoiriens.
Je vois même pas le problème.
Qu'elle a été
historiquement coloniale,
que la France puisse utiliser
la langue française
comme outil diplomatique,
c'est entendu.
Mais la langue française est devenue
africaine depuis des siècles,
au moins des décennies,
au moins un demi-siècle,
c'est entendu aussi.
Les choses ne sont pas
contradictoires mais complexes.
-Vous avez écrit
au président Macron pour lui dire :
"Quel projet de la francophonie
vous voulez faire ?
"J'ai pas l'impression que
vous sachiez ce que vous voulez."
Qu'est-ce qui vous a gêné ?
-J'avais écrit...
Il faut replacer le débat.
C'était à l'époque,
avant qu'il fasse le discours
à l'Académie française.
Il avait fait un discours
sur la francophonie
et la langue partagée.
J'avais regardé,
sur le site de l'Elysée,
et j'avais trouvé deux occurrences
que j'avais commentées.
Je lui reprochais une francophonie
qui était un peu GAFAM,
un peu électronique, etc.
J'étais attaché...
-La francophonie
de la start-up nation.
-Oui.
Dans le premier gouvernement
de monsieur Macron,
il n'y avait plus un ministre
délégué à la francophonie.
Donc je déplorais à la fois
la disparition de la francophonie
comme secrétariat d'Etat,
moi qui y suis attaché,
alors que nos instituts français
sont dans un état lamentable.
-Très abîmés.
-Voilà, je voulais renforcer
la francophonie en France
puisque je suis aussi français,
et d'autre part, que la francophonie
soit pas l'exception
mais la règle de tous les jours,
par exemple,
que dans nos ambassades,
aux instances européennes,
on utilise aussi du français.
Donc que quelque part,
ils soient pas les mauvais élèves
et disent aux francophones
une fois l'an :
"Soyons francophones."
-La langue française
est une langue d'émancipation,
pour vous,
de libération ?
-Les deux.
On peut avoir...
Le gouvernement français
peut utiliser la langue
comme outil diplomatique,
mais elle a été utilisée,
vécue, et a été accaparée,
j'allais dire par exemple,
par les premiers indépendantistes
des pays colonisés.
Quand quelqu'un a été colonisé,
vous lui avez donné un bagage.
Dans son ADN,
vous avez mis quelque chose :
lui ou elle peut utiliser ça.
Par exemple, les indépendantistes
africains, algériens,
voire vietnamiens,
avaient utilisé la langue française
comme outil d'émancipation.
Dans ce cas-là, il s'est raccordé
à l'histoire de la Révolution
ou de la Commune
ou du Front populaire.
Donc on peut très bien l'utiliser,
et je suis fils,
de cette manière-là,
par exemple, d'un Hugo,
on a parlé de Rimbaud, d'un Rimbaud
proche des Communards, par exemple.
C'est l'héritage qui me plaît.
Il peut y avoir une part
de l'héritage qui me plaît moins,
mais je...
-Vous l'assumez ?
-Je fais silence.
Quand vous êtes dans une famille,
vous avez des oncles vertueux
et des oncles moins vertueux.
L'oncle Albert,
qui est moins vertueux,
on le cache, et l'oncle vertueux,
on s'attache à celui-là.
Nous-mêmes, on fait ça
dans notre famille.
-Sur le continent africain,
quel est l'homme
ou la femme politique
qui pour vous,
symbolise justement l'Afrique ?
-Il y a eu des périodes,
je serais d'accord
avec Souleymane Bachir,
pour parfois rédimer
l'image de Senghor, par exemple.
On a très facilement
un peu cassé Senghor alors...
-Vous, vous défendez Senghor ?
-En tout cas
pour son oeuvre culturelle
et pour avoir installé
l'Etat sénégalais.
On n'est pas tous d'accord
avec tout ce qu'il a fait,
mais le fait d'avoir
installé l'Etat,
de lui avoir donné une assise
est tout à fait honorable.
-Et son action
pour la francophonie, aussi.
-J'étudiais en Normandie.
Je l'ai rencontré.
C'était un homme
avec qui on discutait.
Je lui avais écrit
une très belle lettre.
C'est un homme de culture,
et oui, sur sa francophonie aussi.
On a trop facilement décrié...
C'était facile, c'est d'époque.
Normalement, les générations,
elles se forment à...
Comment dire ?
-En opposition ?
-A chercher
des noises aux anciens.
Des générations d'Africains,
d'artistes africains
se sont formés
à casser du sucre
sur son dos.
A l'opposé,
ça me plairait de citer Sankara.
-Thomas Sankara.
-Thomas Sankara
qui était aux affaires
pendant 4 ans et qui vient...
-Président du Burkina Faso.
-Il a créé le Burkina Faso.
L'Etat d'avant
s'appelait la Haute-Volta.
-Le pays des hommes intègres.
-En quatre ans, il a aussi donné
une autre manière de faire pays,
de faire nation, et c'est
très différent des Senghors.
Et moi, je ne suis pas
des oppositions.
J'essaie de trouver
un intérêt, une utilité
et un usage aujourd'hui
historique
chez l'un
et chez l'autre.
-Vous êtes un écrivain
d'origine djiboutienne,
vous écrivez beaucoup
sur la condition sociale,
sur l'histoire,
sur la colonisation.
Est-ce qu'on est nécessairement
un écrivain engagé ?
Vous avez écrit, par exemple,
une fresque en trois volumes
sur votre pays, sur Djibouti.
Le premier volume, ça s'appelait
"Le pays sans ombre", en 1994.
Après il y a eu "Cahier nomade",
vous parliez des nomades,
et les Afars et les Issas,
c'est aussi beaucoup ça,
en 1996.
Et puis "Balbala",
2 ans plus tard.
Tout ça, ça forme une fresque.
Vous estimez que vous êtes
un écrivain engagé ?
-Vous connaissez
la réponse. Je préfère être
un écrivain engageant
qu'un écrivain engagé,
mais "engagé" signifierait
un écrivain
- ou une écrivaine, d'ailleurs -
qui prête attention à son entour,
donc ça ne me dérange pas.
Ca ne signifie pas
qu'on est...
qu'on vulgarise un dogme
ou qu'on essaye de transmettre
un message univoque etc.
Donc pour moi, un écrivain engagé
et engageant, surtout,
avec des thématiques engageantes,
ça signifie un écrivain
qui n'est pas indifférent
à son environnement.
Donc oui,
si ça signifie
un écrivain qui s'intéresse
à son temps,
et qui est de son époque.
-C'est pour ça
que vous êtes allé au Rwanda
et que vous avez écrit
un beau livre, "Moisson de crânes" ?
-Ces projets s'inscrivaient...
A l'époque,
on appelait ça l'inventaire.
C'est Jospin qui était là.
Avec d'autres écrivains
africain de l'époque,
nous nous sommes rendus
à Kigali,
partager un temps de silence
et de deuil avec les Rwandais.
-Vous avez cette fabuleuse phrase
dans ce livre :
"Le malheur danse et sautille
aux bras de l'histoire".
C'est incroyable,
cette phrase, là.
-Oui, je ne sais pas si c'est...
-Si, c'est quand même... En 2008,
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien,
Jean-Marie Le Clézio
obtient le prix
Nobel de littérature,
qui lui-même
connaît bien l'Afrique
pour y avoir beaucoup voyagé,
et pour avoir écrit
sur l'Afrique, aussi.
-"L'Africain",
roman magnifique.
Et son prix Nobel,
il vous le dédie. Et pourquoi ?
Vous êtes très fier de ça.
-Je suis très fier,
et maintenant,
je l'ai entendu et je l'ai lu,
mais la première fois,
j'avais lu cet hommage-là,
j'ai fait trois sauts périlleux
en arrière.
-Ah oui ?
-Non mais évidemment.
Donc Jean-Marie Le Clézio est
d'abord un homme généreux.
D'ailleurs, il cite beaucoup
de gens dans son hommage,
dans son prix...
Le discours du prix Nobel.
Il me cite. Il cite d'autres,
je ne suis pas le seul à être cité.
Donc c'est homme généreux
et, comme je le disais,
qui fait famille. Il cite
des écrivains avec qui il partage
la langue française.
Par exemple, ce qu'on appelle
les écrivains francophones.
Il cite des écrivains
qu'on appelle indigènes
ou autochtones
parce qu'il a le soucis
de fleuves, de rivières...
Ce qu'on appellera maintenant
"l'écosystème".
Il est très imprégné.
Donc il cite plein de gens
qu'il aime.
Et de ce point de vue-là,
c'est un grand frère, on va dire.
-Vous le connaissez bien ?
-Oui, très bien.
-Vous le connaissiez
avant qu'il vous cite ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
On s'est rencontrés dans des salons,
et comme j'étais lecteur,
c'est un homme qui voyage
et qui fait voyager la France,
Maurice,
les lieux où il a habité...
Il habitait
au sud des Etats-Unis
chez les Indiens,
on va presque dire,
dans le Nouveau Mexique :
c'est un homme
qui balade deux mondes
et qui fait rencontrer deux mondes.
J'en profite pour dire
qu'après Jean-Marie Gustave
Le Clézio,
nous avons eu encore
Patrick Modiano et Annie Ernaux.
En 15 ans, nous,
de la langue française,
avons eu trois prix Nobel,
ce qui est exceptionnel.
-Quel est votre écrivain
africain préféré ?
-Il y en a de toutes...
J'allais dire, ça dépend des âges.
J'ai beaucoup aimé...
Pourquoi je dis ça ?
On aurait l'impression
que je n'aime plus.
Mais j'ai fréquenté
des écrivains, des gens
comme Kateb Yacine en Algérie,
comme Chinua Achebe
qui a fait une longue...
-Très grand écrivain.
-Donc vous voyez,
j'aime beaucoup, là encore...
Il est mort aussi,
mais un des plus grands écrivains
que j'aimerais citer,
c'est Aimé Césaire.
-Aimé Césaire,
qui est antillais.
-Martiniquais.
-Martiniquais,
qui était un ami intime
de Léopold Sédar Senghor
et qui est
un des pères de la négritude.
-Grand poète
de la langue française aussi.
-Abdourahman Waberi,
merci.
-Merci.
"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA